these are the busiest winter travel days
at the UK's biggest airports
in London as elsewhere the military was
brought in to replace striking workers
and mitigate long delays we've done a
lot of work to try and reduce that and
minimize any delays at all working with
the operators as you probably were as
the airlines the airports we've got
significant numbers of military
personnel here helping us out volunteers
from across government departments as
well as border Force officers who have
come into the workplace with all that we
don't think there'll be significant
delays we're doing everything we can to
minimize any disruption how was it
getting through border control oh that's
good it's very uh smooth it was fine it
was great no hostels no problem more or
less whatsoever even they're very good
you know very Cooperative passengers
have been told to expect delays during
this the first Christmas in three years
with no covert travel restrictions there
will be days of this maybe even longer
but a hundred thousand people have voted
to go on strike and so in January if the
government still refused to talk did
despite what's going to happen at our
airports on our roads with our driving
tests and with payments to Farmers the
strike will escalate significantly
for now there are confirmed strikes
a festive period across the country as
border Force workers call for a bigger
pay rise than the government's offered
we've got members here who can't pay
their mortgage who are struggling to pay
their rent because of the cost of living
has gone so wildly are and are really
really really struggling all we want to
do is for us as the government's own
employees to be given a fair pay award
so we can cover our Central needs
today it's planes tomorrow it's also
trains as rail workers walk out from 6
p.m on Christmas Eve roads are expected
to be busier than normal intensified by
strikes by national highway workers
Catherine Sky News